for a sample of pure water at 25 degrees
celsius the concentration of hydronium
ion is equal to 1.0 times 10 to the
negative seventh molar because the
concentrations are often very small it's
much more convenient to express the
concentration of hydronium ion in terms
of ph and ph is defined as the negative
log of the concentration of hydronium
ion
since h plus and h3o plus are used
interchangeably in chemistry sometimes
you'll see the ph equation written out
as ph is equal to the negative log of
the concentration of h plus ion so to
find the ph of pure water we just need
to plug in the concentration of
hydronium ions into our equation
so the ph is equal to the negative log
of 1.0 times 10 to the negative 7th
which is equal to
7.00 so the ph of pure water at 25
degrees celsius is equal to 7.
notice that there are two significant
figures for the concentration and there
are two decimal places for the final
answer and that's because for a
logarithm only the numbers to the right
of the decimal point are significant
figures therefore two significant
figures for a concentration means two
decimal places
let's say we have a sample of lemon
juice and the measured concentration of
hydronium ions in solution is 3.6 times
10 to the negative fourth molar since we
have the concentration of hydronium ions
we can simply plug in that concentration
into the equation for ph so the ph is
equal to the negative log of the
concentration of 3.6 times 10 to the
negative fourth which is 3.44
notice that we have two significant
figures for the concentration there we
therefore we have two decimal places in
our final answer
so plugging in negative log of 3.6 times
10 to the negative fourth on your
calculator gives you 3.44 for the answer
however there's a way of estimating the
ph without using a calculator
the first step is to say 3.6 times 10 to
the negative fourth is between one times
ten to the negative fourth and ten times
ten to the negative fourth
ten times ten to the negative fourth is
the same thing as one times ten to the
negative third if the concentration of
hydronium ions is one times ten to the
negative third you can find the ph of
that without using a calculator if you
know your logarithms the ph would be
equal to three
and if the concentration of hydronium
ions is one times ten to the negative
fourth this is a log base 10 system so
the negative log of 1 times 10 to the
negative fourth would be equal to a ph
of four
since 3.6 times 10 to the negative
fourth is between one times ten to the
negative fourth and one times ten to the
negative third the ph of this
concentration must be between a ph of
four and a ph of three and we saw that
with our calculator the ph came out to
be
3.44
let's say we have some cleaning solution
at room temperature which is 25 degrees
celsius and the cleaning solution has
some ammonia in it the concentration of
hydroxide ions in solution is measured
to be 2.0 times 10 to the negative third
molar and our goal is to calculate the
ph of the solution the first step is to
use the kw equation which says that the
concentration of hydronium ions times
the concentration of hydroxide ions is
equal to kw which at 25 degrees celsius
is equal to 1.0 times 10 to the negative
14th
we can go ahead and plug in the
concentration of hydroxide ions into the
kw equation so that's 2.0
times 10 to the negative third
and we don't know what the concentration
of hydronium ions is we'll make that x
and so we're going to solve for x and
this is equal to 1 times 10 to the
negative 14.
solving for x x is equal to 5.0 times 10
to the negative 12
and this is the equal to the
concentration of hydronium ions so the
concentration of hydronium ions is equal
to 5.0 times 10 to the negative 12 molar
now that we know the concentration of
hydronium ions in solution we can plug
that into our equation for ph so the ph
is equal to the negative log of 5.0
times 10 to the negative 12 which gives
11.30
notice since we have two significant
figures for the concentration we need
two decimal places for our final answer
now that we've calculated the ph of
three different substances let's find
where they rank on what's called the ph
scale
the ph scale normally goes from 0 to 14
however it is possible to go below zero
or to go above 14.
we calculated that a sample of pure
water at 25 degrees celsius has a ph of
7.00
that puts it right in the middle of the
ph scale and we say that water is a
neutral substance
an aqueous solution has a ph of 7 is
considered to be a neutral solution
an aqueous solution with a ph less than
7 is considered to be an acidic solution
so for lemon juice we calculated the ph
to be 3.44
which is right about here on our ph
scale
so lemon juice is acidic and as you go
to the left on the ph scale you increase
in acidity
for example if we had a solution with a
ph of 6 and another solution with a ph
of 5 the solution with a ph of 5 is more
acidic
and going back to our equation for ph ph
is equal to the negative log of the
concentration of hydronium ions this is
log base 10. therefore the solution with
the ph of 5 is 10 times more acidic than
a solution with a ph of 6.
because of the way the equation is
written
the higher the concentration of
hydronium ions in solution the lower the
value for the ph
and the lower the concentration for the
hydronium ions in solution the higher
the value for the ph
and if an aqueous solution has a ph
greater than 7 we say that aqueous
solution is basic for example our
cleaning solution with some ammonia in
it had a ph of
11.30 so that's right about here on the
ph scale so we would consider that
cleaning solution with ammonia to be a
basic solution as you move to the right
on the ph scale you increase in the
basicity of the solution
so we've seen that ph is equal to the
negative log of the concentration of
hydronium ions which you could also
write ph is equal to the negative log of
h plus
writing it this way on the right makes
it easier to see how the pattern works
for other situations for example poh
is defined as the negative log of the
concentration of hydroxide ions so we
have the poh here and then we have the
concentration of hydroxide ions over
here the same way we wrote ph with the
concentration of h plus ions over here
and also pkw would be equal to the
negative log of kw
let's go back to the kw equation which
says that the concentration of hydronium
ions times the concentration of
hydroxides is equal to kw
if we take the negative log of both
sides of this equation and we use our
log properties we get that the negative
log of the concentration of h3o plus
plus the negative log of the
concentration of oh minus is equal to
the negative log of kw
the negative log of the concentration of
h3o plus is just equal to the ph so we
can write the ph down here plus the
negative log of the concentration of
hydroxide ions that's equal to the poh
so we have ph plus poh
is equal to the negative log of kw
is equal to pkw
at 25 degrees celsius kw is equal to 1.0
times 10 to the negative 14. therefore
the negative log of kw
is the negative log of 1.0 times 10 to
the negative 14
which is equal to
14.00
so we can plug in 14.00
in for pkw which gives us a very useful
equation that says that the ph plus the
poh
is equal to
14.00 and this equation is true when the
temperature is 25 degrees celsius